bonsoir à messieurs merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france les
discussions sur le dossier de la pêche
piétine comment peut-on s'en sortir
comment est-ce que satin passe peut-être
à dépasser paul thompson
je pense que il y a une dimension
politique et une dimension technique et
il
faut travailler sur les années de plomb
mais surtout sur le plan technique je
pense et je ne suis pas un expert de ces
de ces questions de pêche
mais il me semble que ce qui
conviendrait de faire c'est de regarder
à un par un les les différents cas où
les autorités britanniques estiment que
des des éléments de preuve suffisants
date n'a été fournie et et les
décortiquer et
est
plus tranché cadre où campent encore
jeune et je ne vois pas d'autres
d'autres approches qui permettent de
d'agir dans le calme et le respect
rupture ce n'est pas par des
dénonciations
la portant sur la bonne foi des uns ou
des autres peut on va résoudre le
problème semble-t-il mais le problème
france 4 buts c'est qu'il ya aussi un
souci de cohérence au niveau des
chiffres au niveau du nombre de navires
en tête de licences de pêche pour
rejoindre les eaux britanniques par
exemple le le ministre d'état
britannique qui parle de 86 navire a qui
n'ont pas encore reçu de licence de
pêche la france de son côté évoque 200
avions
oui alors nous ne jouerons pas commenté
ces chiffres parce que je ne sais pas
d'où vient ces incohérences
france 80
alors pour rebondir tout d'abord aux
propos de contrats dits
évoque un problème politique moi je
serais tenté de dire que c'est avant
tout un problème culturel et un problème
psychologique
les français sont des juristes de droit
romain qui tiennent aux accords à la
lettre et à l'esprit de la lettre les
britanniques et les anglo saxons sont
d'excellents commerçants qui lorsqu'il
conclut un accord engrange les bénéfices
et re ligue aussi les obligations alors
que l'encré de l'accord n'est pas encore
sèche il faut le savoir parce qu'il faut
avoir une vision globale de ce que sont
nos difficultés réciproques dans la
mesure où je rappelle qu'il ya déjà eus
récemment la faire des sous marins dans
laquelle le britannique ont derrière
notre dos négocier avec l'australie et
les états unis pour nous dérober un
contrat extrêmement important et il ya
aussi vous l'avez vu vous l'avez dit
vous-même il ya quelques instants les
difficultés liées à l'irlande du nord
nous avons vraiment une difficulté de
méthodologie une difficulté de forme
d'esprit qui est agra
connaître à la personne tonitruante du
premier ministre britannique qui est que
en quelque sorte une sorte de donald
trump de bonne famille donc tout cela ne
rend pas facile à une négociation
apaisées entre partenaires respectueux
et de bonne foi et pour vous répondre
précisément il avait été convenu que
tous les navires qui pêchaient entre
2012 et 2016 dans certaines zones
territoriales pourraient obtenir des
licences de pêche tout d'abord les
britanniques ont commencé à dire qu'il
fallait prouver y avoir pêché au moyen
de géolocalisation alors qu'on sait que
les petits marins pêcheurs n'ont pas ces
méthodes de géolocalisation ensuite les
britanniques refusent d'accorder des
licences de pêche à tous les marins
pêcheurs qui ont remplacé leurs navires
depuis 2016 ce qui inquiète parce que
cela veut dire que même les licences
qu'ils accordent à présent on n'est pas
certain que lorsque les bénéficiaires
céderont leurs navires ils conserveront
leur licence donc je suis d'accord pour
la négociation au cas par cas mais il me
semble qu'il est indispensable car
rapport de force établi ce pour ne pas
nous laisser embarquer par les pieds et
que la france a raison de dire que c'est
un problème européen et non pas
uniquement un problème national
c'était à l'union européenne de discuter
avec le royaume-uni d'égal à égal que
chacun y trouve son compte mais en
respectant la parole et l'esprit de
l'apa
paul thompson alors censure les chiffres
injustement qu'on était avancé ce débat
autour des chiffres on a vu que lors de
la rencontre entre david frost et
clément bonne les deux ministres
français qui se sont rencontrés à
bruxelles qui doivent poursuivre un peu
les discussions et là on a vu ces
dissensions au niveau des chiffres mais
justement sur la question européenne
plus largement un qu'évoque france 80 il
ya la question aussi nord-irlandaise qui
s'invite dans ce débat ce que vous vous
pensez que tellement pour à boris
johnson s'est ses négociations avec la
france là autour des licences de pêche
c'est un moyen de faire pression sur
paris pour éventuellement en vue d'une
négociation sur la question leur
irlandaise
je ne pense pas je pense que ce sont
deux sujets qui sont des sujets
sensibles depuis
belle lurette et qui mobilise
depuis des années la communauté des
pêcheurs en france
aussi au royaume-uni et la problématique
de vent du nord est un un vrai sujet
très complexe a écrit également
préoccupe
beaucoup de gens depuis des années est
temps qu'il se trouve que ces deux
problèmes sont sur la table en même
temps si vous voulez
mais je pense qu'ils aient le
préférable de l'est
se sont réellement des preuves directes
et je ne pense pas que ce soit par tecmo
prometteur de les mélanger à et en ce
qui concerne la problématique de l'eau
q7 encore moins
pertinent de le mélanger
avec les deux autres
bien sûr il y à un clan politique qui
existe qui est très important dans le
royaume uni et la france sont deux pays
qui sont voisins depuis un certain temps
a qui sont condamnés à bien vivre
ensemble et à s'entendre ils se
disputent régulièrement depuis
milan et
[Musique]
et
non en même temps ils ont des rapports
dans le domaine politique dont un
militaire du renseignement très proche
et qui fonctionne très bien et
honnêtement je ne pense pas que ces
questions que ce soit venant du nord ou
de l'âme de la tâche qui sont des
caisses moins importants vont vraiment
bouleversé la donne sur le plan
politique et donc je pense que on
trouvera des solutions d les deux pays
ont un intérêt primordial
un trouver des solutions
pragmatiques qui permettent à chacun de
d'estimer qu'il n'est pas
lésé ou pas tous les et que l'autre ait
trouvé d'accord france 91 une solution
qui va être trouvée parce que il ya
quand même des tensions puisque paris
menaçant de prendre des mesures de
rétorsion on a le sentiment aussi que
pour londres vient finalement ça ne
compte pas beaucoup ça ne pèse pas
beaucoup dans la balance
mais c'est à dire que je pense que
bien malheureusement la france a souvent
donné l'impression d'être un pays faible
alors que nos amis britanniques eux
donnent l'impression d'être extrêmement
risque et donc je pense que le président
va kron a raison de deux dash permet
clairement nos positions et de les
défendre mais ceci en vue de trouver un
accord et vidal
simplement nous avons trop souvent donné
l'impression d'être trop faible et trop
conciliant et les britanniques qui sont
de bons commerçants qui sont de bons
négociateurs
fontcaude cas effectivement de ce que
nous disons parce qu'il pense qu'il n'y
a que des paroles alors il faut des
actes et lorsqu'il dit il y aura des
axes sont des pragmatiques
on peut leur faire confiance ils
trouveront une solution nous sommes
effectivement un vieux couple de voisins
nous trouverons une solution est dans un
rapport de force équilibrés
c'est tout simplement ce que fait le
gouvernement français pas le talent ça
doit penser que s'il y a des mesures de
rétorsion à bord et johnson va trier
honnêtement je ne pense pas que ce soit
dans ces termes qu'il faut apposer le le
problème et je montre s de dire que
hoarau menez à eux ne sous-estime
absolument pas là
les
l'état dans la ténacité de capacité de
défendre ses intérêts de la france
absolument je ne peux pas
il ya une quelconque sous-estimation de
ce côté là et bien sûr il est tout à
fait normal que la france
avec mémé macron de prison de la france
défend des intérêts français
c'est évident
je ne pense pas que
boris diaw
jeu avant en réalité je pense que c'est
un peu les inverse c'est à dire que
pendant de négociation du président
madame mais une fin très honorable
a néanmoins n'a pas très bien défendu
les intérêts du royaume uni et du coup
les l'équipe wam unissent les ces
incidents sur de nombreux sujets et
l'équipe bantam qui est plus soudée et
déterminée parce qu'ils étaient tous
vraiment pour le président alors que
dans l'équipe de truismes et la moitié
était pas vraiment progressé donc il
faut un changement dans la dynamique
et
l'équipe opérations cela va juste
répondant que c'est de tuer mais ça
c'est vrai mais c'est normal aussi mais
moi je pense que les idées
respect mutuel n'emportera et encore une
fois je pense que
il faut
la réalité politique est toujours là il
est en élection en france l'année
prochaine donc c'est aussi un facteur
qui joue quoi
elle
il faut que les juristes les experts de
la pêche
s'attaque à ces problèmes et trouvent
des trous des solutions et les
fournissent aux politiques en disant bon
équilibre et alizée avec ça et je pense
que ça permettrait de résoudre le
problème merci beaucoup à vous france 4
le délégué départemental du modem est
pas le thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france